double the original goal that i had set
and to make that progress over the last
three days we've had
a record number of shots and arms with
over
10 million shots recorded in the weekend
over 10 million shots in three days that
would have been inconceivable in january
the progress we've made on vaccinating
this country is a great american story
the federal government has stepped up
taken responsibility and launched a
massive federal vaccination program
governors and mayors of both political
parties republicans and democrats have
stepped up as well
our military our national guard fema
they have
all been incredible health care
providers community leaders
from all walks of life so many
volunteers of all ages and backgrounds
stepped up as well
my fellow americans look at what we have
done in the past 10 weeks
no other countries come close 100
million
shots in less than 60 days and now we're
moving
to the next 100 million shots in just 40
days
you heard me say many times before our
progress on vaccination is a stunning
example
that there is nothing nothing this
country cannot do if we put our minds to
it
and we do it together but i've also said
i will always give you it straight
straight from the shoulder
our work is far from over the war
against covet 19 is far from won
this is deadly serious we share the
sentiment of dr wolinski
the head of the center for disease
control and
prevention the cdc expressed earlier
today
this is not a time to lessen our efforts
that's what she said we could still see
a setback in the vaccination program
and most importantly if we let our guard
down now we could see
priority not better
you know as many people as we vaccinated
we still have more americans left to go
you know we will administer more shots
in march than any country on earth
but even so we have to give more shots
in april than we did in march
because we're in the life and death race
for the virus that is spreading quickly
with cases rising again new variants are
spreading
and sadly some of the reckless behavior
we've seen on television over the past
few weeks
means that more new cases are to come in
weeks ahead
with vaccines there's hope which is uh
which is a very good thing to state the
obvious
but people are are are letting up on
precautions
which is a very bad thing look
to this point cases have fallen
two-thirds since i took office deaths
have also fallen two-thirds
but now cases are going back up now some
states deaths are as well
you know we're giving up hard-fought
hard-won gains
and as much as we're doing america it's
time to do even more
all of us have to do our part every one
of us
so let me start here first
this week thanks to my administration's
intensive work with
vaccine manufacturers and distribution
efforts
the amount of vaccines that are going to
be available for vaccinated
vaccination sites will be a new record
33 million doses of vaccine this week
by getting more vaccine supply to states
community health centers and pharmacies
we can vaccinate the highest risk
americans more quickly than we already
are
and then and then we make it possible to
open up
supplies for all adults and try to beat
the renewed spread of this virus as a
result i'm also pleased to announce that
we're on track this week
just 10 weeks after i became president
to achieve nearly
75 percent of americans over the age of
65 getting at least one vaccination shot
when i took office in january 20th that
number was eight percent
going to 75 that's a lot of grandparents
are now able to
safely hug their grandchildren they
couldn't do so
just a short time ago and with the
supply
we're releasing this week just this week
alone there are more doors
there are more doses of vaccine
available for seniors this week
than any week thus far so seniors
please if you've not gotten your shot
yet get it this week
get it second i'm reiterating my call
for every governor
mayor and local leader to maintain and
reinstate the mass mandate
please this is not politics
reinstate the mandate if you let it down
and business should require mass as well
the failure to take this virus seriously
precisely what got us to this mess in
the first place
risk more cases more desks deaths
look as i do my part to accelerate the
vaccine distribution and vaccinations
i need the american people to do their
part as well
mask up mask up it's a patriotic duty
it's the only way we ever
get back to normal to cheer together in
stadiums full of fans
to gather together on holidays again
safely
go to graduations weddings
third i announced on march 11th
i direct every state territory and tribe
to open up their vaccinations
to all adults no later than may
1. i issued that order because moving
beyond priority groups
to enable all adults to get vaccinated
is critical to having a july 4th
as closer to normal i want this to come
as quickly as possible
i want to thank the governors democrats
and republicans
who have responded to this directive in
fact the vast majority of governors have
set open access dates
even earlier than the deadline of may
1st
but in this race against the rapidly
spreading virus as fast as we are going
we need to go faster so to make it
easier for americans to get vaccinated
as the supply grows
and vaccination eligibility expands
i'm directing my cova team to ensure
there is a vaccine
site within 5 miles of 90
of all americans by april the 19th three
weeks from today
look we're going to do this by growing
from having
17 000 pharmacies giving out
vaccination shots to nearly 40
000 pharmacies doing it within the next
three weeks
that'll more than double the number of
pharmacies where you can go get
vaccinated
we aren't stopping there in the next
three weeks
we'll add 12 more federally run
mass vaccination sites
every day at these sites tens of
thousands of people
were able to drive up get a vaccine shot
while in their car and leave in less
than an hour
and over 60 percent of the shots given
at these sites goes to minority
communities
because they're in minority communities
we have to reach out they're the ones
most affected by the facts
by both the vaccine but also by the
pandemic
we're also going to send more aid to
states to expand the opening more
community vaccination sites
more vaccines more sites more
vaccinators
all designed to speed our critical work
we also need to make it easier for those
who want
shots but cannot access vaccination
sites to get vaccinated
this is also where we're focused on
the seniors most immediately while we
have made incredible progress
in starting to vaccinate nearly
three-quarters of our seniors
and now putting vaccination sites within
5 miles
of 90 of all americans that still isn't
enough as far as we're concerned
we know that there are a number of
seniors and people with disabilities
who may be isolated and have lack of
access to transportation
and there are community groups that can
help they're trying to help now
so our fourth announcement today is that
i'm sending out
millions of dollars through the
department of health and human services
to provide assistance
including transportation so more
vulnerable seniors
and people with disabilities can get
their shots because they'll get help to
physically get there to get the shot
neighbors helping neighbors
what a truly american effort
we cannot let transportation be a
barrier to any senior getting a
vaccination
and so where's this put us we're making
progress on vaccinations
but cases are rising and the virus is
spreading in too many places still
that's why today i'm taking these steps
to make
our american turnaround story of
our vaccination program move even faster
thanks to all the work we've done these
past 10 weeks
the added steps i'm announcing today
with them i'm pleased to announce
that at least 90 of all adults in this
country
will be eligibly vaccinated by april the
19th
just three weeks from now because we
have the vaccines
for the vast vast majority of adults
you won't have to wait till may 1 you'll
be eligible
for your shot on april 19th finally
10 percent will be eligible no later
than
the final ten percent uh l's will no
later than may one
and as i just said due to the steps
we're taking today
ninety percent of americans will be
within five miles of a location
where they can get a shot as of april
the 19th
so we're moving toward 90 90 by april
19th
that is by april 19th three weeks from
the day 90
of adults people over 18 and over will
be eligible to get vaccinated
90 of all americans will be living
within 5 miles of a place they can get a
shot
and of course will take time for
everyone to get their appointment
it's a big country and as fast as we're
going we still have a long way to go to
finish this vaccination effort
in fact we aren't even there we're only
halfway yet
but being at 90 90 just three weeks from
today
should give hope to the country let me
close with this
the progress we're making is a
significant testament
to what we can do when we work together
as americans
but as i've always said we still need
everyone to do their part
we still are in a war with this deadly
virus
and we're bolstering our defenses but
this war is far
from won together we have so much to be
proud of in the
past three weeks past more than three
weeks past 10 weeks
we also have so much to be sorrowful
about
nearly one 000 americans a day
are still dying from cover 19 as we
approach
550
000 deaths in a single year
until this country is vaccinated each of
us has to do our part we have an
obligation
patriotic obligation wash your hands
stay socially distanced where
a mask is recommended by the cdc
and get vaccinated get your friends and
family vaccinated when you can help
now's not the time to let down
now is not the time to celebrate
it is time to do what we do best as a
country
our duty our jobs
take care of one another and fight this
to the finish
we can and we'll do this but don't let
up now
don't let up now thank you
and may god protect our troops thank you
very much
and dr olenski said she's scared of an
impending doom with covet cases on the
rise are you
i just explained that i think thoroughly
thank you mr president do you believe
that some states should pause their
reopening efforts
yes